Speaker 1: So there's a new study which finds
that legalizing cannabis, also known as marijuana
pot, weed, et cetera, legalizing cannabis lowers
demand for prescription drugs. And this really
shouldn't come as a surprise to us. I mean,
if we want to focus in just narrowly on this,
we know that sometimes cannabis can be a
substitute for pharmaceutical anxiety medication.
We can know that cannabis. We know that cannabis
is sometimes a workable substitute for Big Pharma
sleep medication. We know that cannabis can be a
replacement for opiate pain medication. There's a
long list, and it's not the idea that cannabis is
this panacea cure all substance, but we know from
good studies that in many cases, you can find
a cannabis based alternative for a variety of
different symptoms where you might reach for some
other kind of medication. Now, whether we say it's
better to reach for the cannabis or not, I'm
not even evaluating that in this segment. It
actually doesn't matter for our purposes. But
the point is we know that there is this very
the tentacles of opposition to cannabis
legalization come from a number of different
areas. And now we have a new study which points
very specifically to this aspect of it. There's
a good piece in the hill about this. Legalizing
marijuana lowers demand for prescription drugs,
study finds the reductions in drug utilization
that we find could lead could lead to significant
cost savings for state Medicaid programs. The
results also indicate an opportunity to reduce
the harm that can come with the dangerous side
effects associated with some prescription drugs.
One researcher said I encourage you to read about
the study and the details about the study. But as
I pointed out, they found a decline in the volume
of prescriptions targeting pain, depression,
anxiety, sleep, psychosis and seizures in states
that have legalized recreational use. So what are
the kind of important takeaways as we think about
this as a political issue? It makes a lot of sense
that lots of different elements would want to keep
cannabis illegal, or at least not recreationally
legal. It increases profits in a number of
different areas, I'm only going to mention a few,
there's probably more so. Big Pharma. If you have
widespread recreational cannabis legalization,
Big Pharma profits would likely go down in those
places. Private prisons, we've said before, you
know, private prisons are not as big in the United
States as some people think. I think the last
study I saw says private prison inmates are nine
or 11 percent of federal inmates and like zero
percent or close to zero at the state level. I
believe that that's true. But to some degree,
when you have more reasons why someone
might be imprisoned, that's good for
private prison profits, for sure. The bail
bonds industry, if you take something that's
currently against the law and you make it legal,
fewer people will demand the service of bail bonds
lawyers, right? I mean, to some
degree, if you eliminate a crime,
you will eliminate the need for lawyers to
defend people against charges for that crime.
We also know that cannabis legalization lowers
demand for alcohol. I don't know, but I wonder
if it reduces the demand for cigarets. Maybe
I don't know enough about the cigaret piece to
be able to say for sure, and I'm sure that I'm
missing many here in my discussion of this. So
this is both why, on the one hand, a lot of these
different industries would want to keep cannabis
illegal. Oh, sorry, I forgot a major one. Police
departments seizures, both of drugs, but also of
cash associated with the dealing of cannabis, etc.
That's also another big aspect of this. Police
departments, local police departments receiving
significant moneys as a result of cannabis not
being recreationally legal or even decriminalized
at all. So on the one hand, that's why Big Pharma
would oppose cannabis legalization. But at
the same time, it seems Big Pharma realizes
the writing is sort of on the wall, and Big
Pharma has also been pursuing patents related to
cannabis. So it's like they don't like it until
they take over the business and can monetize it,
at which point they really like it. None of this
should surprise us. And if you've been following
the political discussion around cannabis for
any period of time or for more than a decade,
as we have on the show, you would understand the
incongruity and we could really call it a double
standard or hypocrisy that exists compared to
so many different things. When you look at the
Schedule one federal designation of cannabis
up there with the most damaging and addicting
substances of no medicinal value, when hold
on a second, we we know I mean the study.
Big Pharma concedes that legal cannabis is
a threat to their profits because it is of
medicinal value without calling it a panacea. Of
course, you know that the Schedule one designation
doesn't make any sense. And we've talked about
all of these aspects before. So here is another
one. And I still on this. You know, there was
a period I remember early in the show's history
where we started to see gay marriage legalization
in one state, in another state, in a third, state,
in a fourth state. And at the time, I remember
conversations with the team and with guests.
There was a certain feeling of inevitability
that it's hard to imagine 10 years down the line
that gay couples lesbian couples wouldn't be able
to get married anywhere in the United States.
And indeed, ultimately it happened. I have
a similar feeling of inevitability to some
degree when it comes to cannabis. I don't know how
soon we're going to see recreational legalization
nationally. I don't know about that, but there's a
sense of inevitability that we are heading in the
direction, at least of federal decriminalization.
I don't know when it will come. But there's that
same sort of sense that I have. If you disagree,
let me know I'd be interested in hearing from you.